people seeking the perfect job with an
international employer may well have
found us already the European Union is
not just a political system behind it
all you'll discover surprising career
opportunities and not just within the
institution's headquarters 40,000
employees work in many diverse fields in
its institutions in you a gin seas and
in local offices around the world
together they work for the benefit of
500 million European citizens the EU
offers numerous career opportunities to
candidates from all over Europe highly
specialized professionals are needed as
our flexible all-rounders and this
applies in many areas I'm have no Kamuzu
my name is Sylvia Island my name is
Joanna Peshawar and I come from Paula
I'm French I'm Irish I'm Latvian I'm a
lawyer and I handle cases concerning
environmental law they work as an
interpreter IT project manager I work in
the paymaster office I work for the
development department in the European
Commission the main locations of the
institutions are Brussels and Luxembourg
Brussels is of course the central
location
people from around the world feel at
home here it's a vibrant charming City
and trim as the political heart of
Europe great opportunities for
developing careers and a multicultural
environment those are the hallmarks of
the EU EU citizens who can speak at
least two European languages are welcome
to apply following on from there the
motto is equal opportunities parole and
being with people from around the globe
doesn't just make work the pleasure
social life is good too interested the
European personnel selection office has
comprehensive information for applicants
so who wants to work for a company when
you can work for the whole of Europe
you